so talk me through the idea of heaven
and hell what are you guys hoping for
okay well this is a sort of a
back-to-basics season in a way we were
resurrected by the fans who loved our
show and is like no yes we need the show
back and we're coming into this thinking
of that push and pull between evil and
good that resides in all of us so I
think that's kind of what we're doing
with the house and with the theme this
year yeah I'm really excited to see how
that plays out in real time now have you
sort of put people in the house that
maybe will go to either the evil side or
the good side I mean possibly but truly
the best players are the ones who can do
both right
who can succumb to those darker impulses
but also be there for people when they
need when they need it right but it's
very few time just trying to think of
I've ever seen a winner who hasn't done
anything cutthroat you think that's
impossible you do see people who go in
and they have the feeling that they want
to win honestly or they yeah don't want
to yeah I almost feel like I just I want
to give them a hug when they say that
and I want to whisper in their ear
have you seen right I mean it's it's
kind of a place where people often check
you know their their their real selves
at the door in some ways because
suddenly you have license to do those
things you would never do in real life
but might when you you know $100,000 but
I have seen people go very very far on
that and to be honest I think last year
we had a winner who know I did some
boxes I'm not gonna ask you who you
think will win because you will never
give an answer to that I never will but
let me ask you this what does it take to
win I think it takes a very developed
sense of emotional intelligence yeah
people who are good at reading people
are often quite skilled at manipulating
people should they choose to write
people who are hard to lie to those
people do very very well and I think
I don't even think it comes down to
intellectual people because there's
people who come in super fans of the
game never missed an episode you know of
the Canadian version or the US version
or the British version and you still see
them fumble on some really basic stuff
but truly the thing that you need is
adaptability because even if you have an
amazing strategy that's working this is
Big Brother and you have to expect the
unexpected we will throw everything
except the kitchen sink at these people
and it's the ones who know how to dodge
and weave and and can navigate all of
these changes as they're happening like
right as it's at like it's amazing to
watch somebody who's really good at the
game is really really amazing to watch
yeah and unlike really any other
competition whether it's on a field or
on television the thing that sets Big
Brother Canada apart is that the idea of
a physical threat is often gone out the
window on day one it's the only time
where somebody could walk in and be this
physically imposing force and it can
mean nothing absolutely nothing and
there's so many different kinds of
challenges is is being like a huge tough
person gonna help you in an endurance
challenge probably not yeah he's gonna
help you in tribute or a memory
challenge probably not so I love a game
that sort of you know equals the playing
field or levels the playing field a
little bit where you can be any kind of
person and find your way to the end and
I've seen it happen before I see the
most unlikely person before win and and
that's what keeps it exciting they're
real people these are not actors you
know and it's also one of the only
places where you can celebrate without
risk of judgment a fantastic liar oh I
know I know no it's great it's like it's
not real world rules not really no rules
like as much as as much as you know for
the people who are playing this game it
is their real life it is a superficial
environment that we've created and it's
like the one place where it's like
you're allowed to do you have to do as
long as and if you want to win you need
to be able to own your game at the very
end and if you can own that yeah people
will root for you it's the people I
think who've done say some shady things
or some sketchy things and can't save
they did yeah people often don't won't
respect that player but if you can do
some stuff get through the end and then
you can say that they will root for you
and they will vote for you to win the
fans their level they love everything
about the show but at this point they're
dying to know what is different mmm what
are you telling the fans I am saying
that in the very first episode the game
is kicked into high gear so usually
typically with with the new season new
players yeah sometimes it takes a little
while for people to get warmed up
they're a little bit scared it's a
little bit of groupthink going on
oftentimes you'll find the first couple
of evictions are unanimous votes right
for example so once a target has been
identified by somebody they go it's what
the house was - what the house well as
long as it's not me and they vote for
that person that person's gone okay when
you have new players the way to avoid
that is by doing something something get
or going something and that's something
is coming in and that is episode one
yeah they do not have to wait long
no well Omarosa be coming up Omarosa is
not on Earth season but I love that she
loves Big Brother Canada and I'm here
for that okay so what were your feelings
what did you know that ahead of time the
bellows it was a fan no no I mean I do
know that she loves Big Brother yeah and
I know that she has a friendship with
evil dick right who I don't know if you
know is a former winner of Big Brother
in the US and I could see why they're
friends because both of them were
villains right and truly embraced being
villains which is very rare to find most
people you know they want to fight that
and they come out and they say oh my god
I was the villain and it's like you know
clutching pearls but every once in a
while you find someone who who
completely embraces it and that's so
refreshing for people yeah so the fact
that she you know digs our show I'm not
really surprised that we've got you know
big brother is in something like 48
countries and Big Brother Canada is
known as one of the best we take that so
seriously and that's why we put our like
blood sweat and tears into making every
season the best we can amazing Arisa Cox
thank you so much Big Brother Canada
tomorrow night my girl thank you
ha